dites-moi que serait Noël sans sa
traditionnelle
[Musique]
bûche aujourd'hui je vous invite à
découvrir les desserts d'ici un atelier
àes dents dont la spécialité est
l'ingrédient local et oui depuis 2015
Sophie Lafite régale les gourmand avec
ses créations sucrées bûche financier ou
encore tarte au chocolat et le tout
confectionné avec des ingrédients locaux
comme la farine des moulins de brassuil
la rubarbe de chamboursy ou encore le
chocolat de hardricour et pour Noël je
vous propose donc trois bûches la bûche
au chocolat la bûche à la pomme et au
caramel et la bûche à son tyramide sous
spéculos et sachez qu'une alternatif
sans gluten est également proposé prix
de départ 24 € et pour passer commande
rendez-vous sur le site internet les
desserts d'ici et vous aurez la
possibilité de retirer votre produit
dans une épicerie
partenaire